For most real world problems, it's up to you to figure out how to encode the
inputs and this is one of the most important decisions that you can make in
solving a problem. For the problems that we've used in CS 101, because they need
to be automatically graded and we want to run your code on test but we need to
specify carefully what the inputs are and how they're encoded. In this case, the
template for the problem indicates how the inputs are represented, that there's
six parameters to the daysBetweenDates procedure, year one, month one, day
one, and year two, month two, day two, and that means we're going to be passing
in six different values to represent those two dates. Those of you who've got a
little further in the class will rise that there's better ways we might have
used to package the year, month and day into one object, but based on what we've
seen only through unit two, passing them in as separate values makes sense. So
our solution needs to use inputs represented this way.